Today's Election Day, which means most kids are out of school,
which means most kids had to find child care.
Most mothers had to find child care for their kids,
because unequivocally, moms carry the burden of all this extra stuff,
these extra days off, these random holidays,
these teacher work days. Moms
the one who has to be stuck holding the bag
if she doesn't find child care.
And that's because most women,
working or not, are the primary parent of their children.
And if you don't believe me,
ask your male co workers who have kids,
what their kids are doing today since they're off school.
And if they happen to know what they're doing, ask who set it up.